good
morning good
morning what makes both yosity and ios8
so special is the way that they work
together you can also make and receive
regular telephone calls using your Mac
as a speaker phone hi Stephen it's Craig
from Apple I'm sorry I don't recognize
that name all of you can get access to
usbody on the Mac App Store to
today I'm so excited to be able to tell
you about the incredible new iPad Air 2
it is the thinnest iPad we have ever
made we've now created an
anti-reflective coating for this
multi-touch surface a whole new
generation chip 64-bit architecture it
has three billion transistors the
original iPad started with an A4 chip
and now we're 12 times faster than that
it's a full new 8 megap pixel eyesight
camera it takes photos and 1080p HD
video the most requested feature from
customers is Touch ID and now with Touch
ID you'll be able to use Apple pay to
make online purchases it comes in silver
space gray and the new gold that you've
seen here and it starts at $4.99 we have
an update today for iPad Mini as well we
call it iPad Mini 3 and of course it
includes the new touch ID feature as
well it will start at$
3.99 $4.99 and 5.99 we'll take
pre-orders tomorrow October 17th we are
so excited to tell you about the all new
iMac with retina display we call it the
retina 5K display it's going to cost
$24.99 we have one other small update
today it's called Mac Mini it's updated
with faster processors the new faster
more capable Mac Mini starts are just
for
99 thanks very much for joining
us